we are now live
assalamu alaikum
it's your boy she's here we're back with
another Banger live stream we got a very
special guest he got the best one of the
co-hosts of the best podcast in the
Dunya if y'all don't know I'm gonna let
him introduce himself I'll let you out
the floor well
she thank you for having me man I'm a
co-host of the realist podcast in the
Dunya the three Muslims you already know
and to any of our t3m fan members that
are here you probably recognize brother
Sheed from our stream when he took the
shahada alhamdulillah so what's changed
bro since then
a lot of chances then Ramadan was right
around the corner from that so I had a
great Ramadan experience if everybody
wants to know like the details of that
my Ramadan was amazing I was in the
master a lot I met a lot of new people
and it's just being around being around
the community that was like one of the
best things and it actually you know I'm
saying put me more focused on the dean
like way more focused like and then like
the iftars together and everything like
that breaking the fast and all of you
all on the same page and everything man
and like one thing too I tried so many
foods so many foods that I never had
like like uh Middle Eastern food like
Middle East food had a lot of a lot of
that like did you did you have any
Buckle over
bro that stuff's gonna make you weak bro
it's so easy to slip into having a whole
box come on no ah yeah that uh goat lamb
just so delicious so delicious I love my
buttock man and how was your first
actual Ramadan like physically because I
know a lot of people that are reverts no
food it's one thing but no water too
yeah intense so
at first I'll be honest it was very hard
at first like and that's what I heard
from a lot of people that was telling me
that as well like the first couple weeks
you're gonna go through it but then
after that it gets uh it gets easier
over time and it's like uh see the only
thing like I had to realize I realized
there's two during the month you know uh
fatger keeps pushing back like every day
it goes back so like when it's around 5
30 a.m it's good but when it starts
hitting 4 a.m you gotta you gotta get up
for sahore you got to get up
but yeah it was uh whole experience it
was it was very good like I said I read
a lot of Quran I learned a lot one thing
I'm trying to do now is learn it like
learn Arabic to learning this original
language and everything like that
because I'm trying to get better with
that you know because I feel like uh
because I also heard that it's some
words that cannot be translated into
English and everything like that so
that's why I do want to that's what the
that's my next goal for the rest of the
year is try to you know get Arabic down
pack and everything but what have you
been up to bro I just just saying you
doing a lot of different things I see
you went to Dubai podcast with snico
Hamdi live you guys are growing channels
like at 160k right now so inshallah
inshallah you'll be at a million soon
but let's let's hear about what you had
I'm the Man honestly I've been you are
the first person to ask me that bro in
in a long time because I I live by a
philosophy where I like to talk less and
do more and we're surrounded by men that
talk more and do less so for me I I
genuinely took the last few months to
focus on T3 I'm with the boys with
brother Angel and Romy shout out to them
too and uh just you know focus on my
coaching business if I'd fit I coach
Muslim men to level up and that's a
little bit about what we're going to
talk about today right and we want to go
into your story and my story too and
inshallah it's kind of like talking
about our stories that can Inspire them
and there's a little bit of wisdom here
and there along the way uh also did a
little bit of traveling last couple of
months we did umra as well which for a
lot of the non-muslim people that don't
know what omura is it's one of the
voluntary pilgrimages as Muslims right
so we have Hajj which is a big
pilgrimage that Muslims are obligated to
do provided we can afford it right right
right
um and we have the privilege and ability
to do so
but umra is good too and we went to umra
right before Ramadan with me angel Rami
and we went with uh brother wahab so if
you guys know the Warner from YouTube as
well we went with him too and that's
where we met shooter we met a couple
other people a couple other brothers
alhamdulillah we were initially supposed
to go to film a podcast with Andrew Tate
believe it or not yeah and what happened
was we filmed that we we planned that
well in advance with with Jewel with uh
sartorial shooter and close to December
the Tay Brothers got locked up right you
already know yeah and now we're thinking
you know Jules you know back in touch
with us and and he's telling us you know
inshallah he might be out by then so we
could still do the podcast so we kept
the data and everything yeah at the end
of the day we planned that we plan to go
to umrah after plane tickets are
non-refundable bro right so at this
point listen we're going there no matter
what regardless right and as the days
get closer Jewel tells us he wants to
convert to a slab or like really and
he's like yeah let's do a podcast
together music of course yes and then he
hits us up again and says he already
converted to Islam and we were like okay
listen Tate renote we're getting shooter
no matter what oh yeah
Hondo hundo and that's that's when we
went you know beautiful wonderful
brother he invited us to his own home
you know we ate together he showed us
around his crib his collection of a lot
of different things that some I'm not
going to mention and it was very nice
alhamdulillah shout out to him and his
family yeah and it was a beautiful base
you know we we had plans to make a
little mini studio in his house right we
planned one thing Allah plans another so
we ended up filming in his balcony which
is where he saw the podcast with the
Masjid in the back
oh wow like yeah cause like I said I
watched uh podcast and everything that
you guys have done it's just like I said
and they're just seeing you guys growth
like I said like a lot I don't know if
people give you guys your flowers but
you guys are doing a great thing for the
Uma you guys are doing a very great
thing like I'm the little man or Crystal
uh yeah you got you gotta really do
inspire a lot of people and I'm pretty
like everybody watches you understand
like you do Aspire a lot of people and I
I advise you guys to keep doing what
you're doing like I said it's a lot of
blessing down the road with the path you
guys going on but I want to talk about
the topic of uh men's self-improvement
because you were saying there's a lot of
men not doing enough so I want to give
your uh I want you to tell us about what
how what ways you think men can
self-improve
so I want to go over a little bit of a
about a couple different things and you
know that way the the viewers can kind
of mentally just jot down that these are
topics that are very important right
these are very important I guess
variables in the game of leveling up to
become a high value man not just in
Dunya but in the eyes of Allah right
because Islam is very beautiful Islam
doesn't leave us for too much
speculation because Allah knows when
mankind is left to interpretation and
speculation they create the parameters
on their own right this is why a lot of
man-made ideologies like let's say our
pill and Femme and I don't want to
mention any of these to get censored and
a lot of these they they have good truth
in them but then they also have
falsehood right and Mankind is not
qualified enough to discuss and derive
these parameters on their own right so
that's why Islam tells us exactly what
to do I'm sure as a Reverb bro sometimes
you might have felt in the very
beginning like oh there's a lot of rules
there's a lot of restrictions but then
eventually you come to realize that
anything that Allah tells you is Haram
is generally Haram for a reason yeah
it's a reason it's a reason exactly
exactly so similarly there's there's a
there's a bunch of things that I want
men to focus on and these things are
generally going to help them level up
and I think it's absolutely important
that we we step on this if we delay this
you know we're not getting younger right
and death is guaranteed bro for every
single soul so with this being said the
first most important thing I think that
men should strive to achieve is a level
of spirituality and closeness to Allah
now a lot of non-muslims listening to
this is what who is Allah who is going
on here you know or are they trying to
are they trying to radicalize us on
stream bro listen so be it at the end of
the day there's one Creator there's one
God everyone knows this right this one
Creator this one God Allah
in Arabic right he created me he created
you he created the heavens and the Earth
the Angels the shayateen the Jinn
all the animals he created everything
the thing is unless you are a Muslim you
will never have the level of connection
to Allah as you will with anything else
now this doesn't mean I'm throwing
disrespect to any other religion and if
you're sincere with your religion and
you do your research inshallah will
guide you to Islam right well the point
is and brother she can testify to this
because he wasn't a Muslim was he no it
wasn't about no exactly so so in a quick
like 10 second nutshell how did you find
Islam by doing my own researchers like
like you gotta you gotta read like I
said you gotta look at it why advise
people to do non-bias no don't do not
have bias going into it do not listen to
what society would tell you about Islam
just go open up the Quran that's why I
advise everyone to do just opened up
non-bias for the non-muslim watching and
just read it because you'll realize that
a lot of the things in there makes a lot
of sense everything in there is like
everything's Justified and it makes
sense like it's it's a laugh it's a
truth it's basically the truth you got
to read it yourself that's how you'll
learn it you got to read it and now I'm
biasing word bro where that's literally
what it is yeah and once you come to
Islam that's when you can begin your
spiritual journey to Allah and come
closer to Allah so this would be first
and foremost this is kind of
non-negotiable yeah because at the end
of the day many people live in the Dunya
and they're embedded into the Dunya
right they're too plugged into the
Matrix right so when you're too plugged
into the Matrix you walk around thinking
you know what everything that I can see
exists right anything that I can't see
doesn't exist right so because our
spirit our soul is something that you
can't really see right scientists they
can't really look at a brain scan and be
like you know what I can I can point
right there that's where your
Consciousness or where your soul is
located they can't do that they still
can't do that so because we have the
spirit the soul
it's very important and our soul is part
of this ethereal unseen realm right that
only Allah is aware of right the thing
is our body is something we're aware of
yeah if your body is not kind of
congruent with your spirit with your
soul you are going to experience a level
of dissonance bro right and you are
going to feel this no matter how much
money how much clout how much Fame these
are things the worldly uh delusions will
I guess tempt you with yeah women how
much anything right exactly so if you're
if you're not one in mind body and
spirit you're gonna feel that dissonance
this is why this connection with Allah
comes first and foremost some people are
spiritually hungry bro yeah because of
this it manifests itself in Eating
Disorders maybe maybe and the problem is
why am I eating why am I doing this it's
not a problem up here yeah it's a
problem down here yeah with your spirit
right and the same thing could be let's
say you're you're depressed spiritually
right you feel like you know what can I
be forgiving can I be this maybe you
just don't understand the mercy of Allah
yet right homework and because of the
that you'll actually have clinical
depression in real life right so these
things are very linked but if you get
your spirit and your your soul in check
by coming close to Allah everything else
works out bro right and like I said I do
want to uh tie into what you just said
about like getting your spirit and
everything in order because if you like
like you basically saying if you think
about it if you let this if you just
leave with what the world wants you to
do like because we all know we'll use
the Matrix for the time what the Matrix
portrays at you they want you to get all
these women all these cars and all that
it's not going to satisfy you it's not
once you get everything because that's
how you get everything once you get it
you're still gonna be hurting in the
inside that's gonna be the first thing
that's gonna like if you don't get that
in order you're never going to truly
self-improve no matter what like I said
you could do all that but guess what a
lot of them be going to drugs a lot of
them do a lot like a lot of these rich
people do a lot of different things just
because of the stuff that the world
portrays on them and they realize
they're not happy internally so I feel
like the only way to satisfy because
what I learned in this world is always
something that you're gonna want always
it's always something you don't want
you're never gonna Never Gonna not want
a new car new and it always something
it's always something you're going to be
able to strive for but when you uh put
your faith in Allah that's when you
realize that everything everything in
this world it doesn't matter it doesn't
like it's little it's little compared to
the greatness of Allah and everything
like that and that gives you something
to really strive for and put your effort
in and everything and you do that the
stuff the stuff in the world doesn't
matter it doesn't it doesn't rule the
illuminum buttock man that's literally
what it is because Hedonism itself it's
right it's a black hole the more more
that you go the more that you want the
more that you crave yeah that's one
level of looking at the at the problem
right the second level which is a little
bit deeper is the more that you level up
in Dunya without leveling up internally
in your spirit the more that you have a
gap between who you are and who you
think you are right and who you are is
really your spirit your soul that's
truly who you are right that's behind
closed doors lights are off curtains are
you know fully shut and you're just in
the company of your own space surrounded
by nothing but the angels in the gin and
Allah is watching over you right how you
feel that's the real you right Instagram
that's not the real YouTube That's not
the real you yeah so when you don't
level up here internally and you're
leveling up in the Dunya you're gonna
get more and more of that dissonance
that we spoke about right so that's
what's very important that you become
more congruent and you actually do the
inner work without just leveling up with
finances right and with Dunya and with
Social Circle and education alone now
these things are not bad but they don't
come first bro right
that's the same thing I believe like
firstly firstly what you should do is
just put your put your uh your mind and
everything towards towards God so you
got a purpose and you know what to do
like once you get everything you know
what to do with it like I said you'll be
humble with with uh everything you earn
in your life and everything you do with
like so you'll gives a cut you'll do
you'll do things that what you're
supposed to do with your wealth because
a lot of gifts of who he was as well so
you know what I'm saying that's that's
another thing another thing I want to
touch on too is social media like like
you had said about it social media what
I want to tell people men especially
social media you see everybody's
highlight reel uh yeah I know everybody
see what's on social media with these
rappers singers all that you see
everything they're doing you see all
these cars all these mansions and all
that you they're not happy in the inside
I promise you a lot of them are not
happy in the inside so like I said they
had something to put their mind on and
they have focusing a lot they you I said
you'll see them move completely
differently and everything like that
like you see all most of them are on
drugs to be honest most of them people
are on drugs crazy and everything like
that like all the all this stuff is like
basically what we're saying was very
important I think men need to really tap
in more with their religion before
anything else before anything else I
recommend everybody getting as focused
on The Dean as you can because like I
said you once you
once you go astray from it you realize
like everybody realize once they go
astray cause
when I was a non-muslim
like I said I used to uh I used to party
a lot and all kind of things like that
but then after that I used to feel bad
about it because I was like
why am I doing this
but I realize that's internal that's
something I had to learn myself because
that was internal because that that
stuff don't make me happy it makes you
makes you feel good in the moment but
afterwards you'd be like why did I do
this it's no purpose that's what makes
your physical vessel feel good yes and
inebriated but then it actually damages
your spirit in the same time
facts facts facts but yeah that's
exactly how I was feeling though so
that's one reason why why when I turned
to like turn to a lot and everything
like that my life is so I've been I've
been happier like I've literally been
happier just because of me having faith
in a lot and I always know what's what
should I do what's my next move should
be like I judge my moves off of what the
Quran says I'm like okay should I do
this should I do this you know I want to
live a life and that's what I think all
men should do try to live a life their
lives pleased with don't live a life
that this that is done yet it's done you
please because the thing is everybody
has to have an account for the action on
the last day I want to specify that
that's a major part of self-improvement
everybody gonna have to account for the
action on their on the last day so do
you want to just take your time and try
to impress these people these people
here
they're not going to help you on the
last day that nobody's gonna have you
got to account for your actions so you
you should take well I advise people to
do is take all that energy you're
putting into the Dunya and put into a
law because a lot that's that's where
the that's what Paradise is this doesn't
matter this is temporary this is
temporary until the last day but stay
good this is temporary worldly delusion
bro what the Dunya was made for bro this
is what the Matrix was made for I was
speaking to someone about this and I'll
top on this in a bit but right I wanted
to say you're right bro on the day of
judgment yeah it's it's like bro a
mother is basically going to abandon her
newborn baby on that thing because every
soul is going to be held into account
individually right it doesn't matter
you're not gonna get any handouts you're
not going to get you know any co-signs
on that day you can't ask your friends
to revive you nothing not none of that
bro it's like whatever you have built
and established with your deeds and your
relationship and your affair with Allah
that's all that's going to hold right
soundness of your heart that's it you're
Salah that's it that's it not much more
than that and I do want to touch on that
point about social media that you said
that no I think I read this post of
yours if not it was like a story or a
real but you were saying if men spent a
fraction of the time that they do spend
portraying this this facade on social
media in their actual lives yeah they
would be 10 times ahead compared to
where they are
facts that is facts like I said you
downside that's why I advise people to
do though like I said you gotta that's
gonna be your main thing to do like the
other stuff this comes after that
because we're going to Deep dive into
the stuff after that too but the main
thing I feel like you should do is just
get focused on your religion because
that's gonna give you that's gonna lay
down your whole self-improvement journey
because you're gonna know how to do it
in a way that Allah is pleased with so
that's definitely going to help you out
but
after that after at the religion part I
feel like uh a lot of men
they do have like a lot of mental
problems per se I feel like that like
mental health is like I don't know why
especially like see I live in America
and my people from America you guys know
it's like America doesn't care about
mental health but mental health is a
real thing but what I advise people to
do like I I'm not I'm not a person
that's never gonna say get help I feel
like you should go get help with uh your
problems and everything like that like
don't sit here and just let it get out
of control that you have to do something
like drugs or something like that to
feel like feel like yourself again like
it's okay to feel that way but it's what
you do with it and what I advise what I
normally do is this how I handle my
problem so if I feel like I'm depressed
or something like that I'm gonna hit the
gym I'm gonna hit the gym I'm gonna go
do something to take my mind off of that
something that's going to help me better
myself and my mind and my spirit and
everything that's why I choose to do in
my time to get rid of those thoughts and
everything like that because of course
we all are going to feel depressed at
some a moment in our lives all of us are
it's like it's a bad it's always going
to be a bad day coming that's one thing
I learned like no matter how good your
days go it's gonna be a bad day coming
and it's what you do with those with
that bad days like
and also that we can go back to uh the
topic of Allah too with that like that's
why I say it's definitely good to keep a
line yo keep thinking about a lot all
the way through even if it's good days
or bad days that's one thing that's good
too because if you're doing that
every day because you know some people
they like to think about it only on only
on the times they go bad like when
things go bad they like to pray and
everything no pray on the good times too
that's how that's how it's exponential
growth right there that's how you know
you keep yourself going and everything
like that but yeah I advise people to
hit the gym like when they're going
through stuff do that do something find
you something that you're passionate
with and put your time into that because
depression I I feel like it's more
mental thing I always tell every
Everybody watch me every every mint
everything that you got in your uh mind
it could be fixed but you gotta get
control of this
if you don't have control of your mind
you can't solve no problems because like
that I have people that we uh you know
coming to the my channel talking about
nofap a lot and they got issues with
that and I'd be like
it's mental it's mental you have to get
control of your mind more than anything
else because you can't control you can't
control anything in your life like
nothing nothing uh nothing's of your
control it doesn't matter like you don't
you can't control if you walk outside
that you can get hit by a car all that
stuff none of that stuff you control but
you control your mind like I said you
could choose what you want to look at
you could choose everything you have to
get control of your mind that's how you
solve any problem it's mind control
I'm gonna let you add on to that I love
that bro I love that listen yeah I think
all these different topics let's see
finances yeah mental health physical
health nofap all of these things
relationships we're gonna go into all of
them I did want to give a quick
disclaimer number one that all the
things that we talked about thus far
like Dean being number one if there was
an order or hierarchy of priority that's
number one
the second thing is all of these things
that we're going to mention now there's
no priority so I don't want you guys to
think one is more important than the
other I think that these are all
multi-dimensional approaches to how to
level up as a man and you should tackle
all of them simultaneously there's no it
doesn't mean you're focusing on Mental
Health like brother she is saying at the
expense of physical health you can do
both matter of fact one can help the
other like brother she the same yeah and
you don't gotta now wait till finances
for later you can literally level up in
all of them simultaneously so I do want
to give that disclaimer that Islam is
first all of these worldly Donia level
ups but they're also for the two and
they they help you for the sake of Allah
right these things we can focus on them
all at the same time right so let's
let's go into it with the first thing
mental health so there's a big taboo on
Mental Health I'm sure you know this you
know in America and just generally in
the world bro even in East Asia bro
mental health is just glossed over right
and people have trauma people have PTSD
people of depression anxiety substance
addiction they don't know what's wrong
with them
we're going to keep it very simple today
right this is not medical advice I'm not
going to be liable in any way whatsoever
or anything but I'm about to say all
right everything is just for
entertainment purposes only come on no
yeah
number one
you have two types of problems mentally
all right now A lot of people are like
what aren't mental problems all up here
listen you have physiological problems
and then you have psychological problems
right any problem you will have
with your mental health when it comes to
a psychological level this is up here
right this is going to be because of
anxiety depression there could be like a
neurotransmitter imbalance we'll talk
about what all these things are
um some level of traumatic experience
grief sadness unprocessed emotions
childhood abuse any of these right these
are psychological problems for your
mental health now the second type is
physiological problems so these stem
from the actual physical hormone
cortisol a lot of people don't know what
cortisol is but it's the stress hormone
in the body so this is another way that
and I know you talked about you know
problems always up here you're right
that's that's strictly for psychological
when it comes to physiological stress
the cortisol we got to deal with that
accordingly it's a little bit different
but it's very similar to what you said
yeah and these two approaches will
basically help you with your mental
health now when it comes to
psychological problems mentally right
this could be anxiety this could be
depression this could be anything right
bro it's completely normal there's no
taboo everyone goes through it matter of
fact the prophet sallam himself was very
distraught at certain times in if you
study the Syrah and this is when Allah
revealed Allah reveals Surah and another
Surah I believe and these basically came
to remind them that you know what you're
not alone right and it it specifically
mentioned that he was actually going
through a very tough time mentally and
he was kind of losing hope and kind of
like what's going to happen you know as
they said it's worth it you know we
can't go as far as to say that he was
thinking of doing anything right we
don't know that right so we can't we
can't speak out of place but he was
definitely mentally distraught and he
was going through a lot of the emotions
that we go through there's nothing
different so the main takeaway here is
if you have these emotions number one
understand they're completely normal
mental problems psychiatrically speaking
right anxiety depression all of these
I'm personally going to say not to go
have any medications such as
antipsychotic medications anti-depress
Essence anxiolytics this is just a
personal thing right I'm not telling you
to be in contravention to what your
medical practitioner is telling you that
is not what I'm trying you know trying
to get to you I'm just saying 99 of the
things that you have mentally will go
away if you do what I say without taking
these prescription medications bro
because big Pharma I think it's on an as
needed basis if at a certain point you
need to be tranquilized bro you're
having a panic attack there's no other
way that's a different story bro I'm
talking about the guy that just has a
bad day right he goes to his doctor and
the doctor says you know what you're
weird for having a bad day let me give
you this pill and you're gonna need two
of these a day for life right bro you
could have just had one bad day and now
you're on something for life right so
the main thing
is understand that we all have trauma we
all have some type of abuse mentally
physically emotionally
um and we've been through things it's
normal
but you kind of have to let this baggage
go if you want to help yourself heal and
the way that you do this versus again
this is only psychological things right
it's not physiological yet number one is
prayer if you start praying Salah to
Allah and not just the obligatory
prayers but the voluntary prayers you
cry out to Allah right the same
Christianity bro we got a confession
stand with the priest none of that bro
to another human being who sins himself
none of that bro you have Allah and you
are praying out to him you're crying out
to him you're telling him all your
problems this is number one it's very
therapeutic and it puts you in a state
of
basically means trusting Allah when you
have trust in Allah you let go of the
things that you have no control over to
the most high right and you only focus
on the things that you can control
so it automatically takes this huge
weight off your shoulders this is number
one number two is you can do either
meditation or journaling or a
combination of the two the thing with
meditation is it's very simple give a
quick like bullet point way of what
meditation is you basically just sit
down with your thoughts right and it's
probably I prefer you do it in the dark
not with a lot of people and you're just
going to be thinking about nothing
wait what if I just say think about
nothing how do you think of nothing I
have work bills finances relationships
you know parents there's some things
happening listen the first couple days
of you taking 10 15 minutes closing your
eyes and just breathing it's probably
just gonna be you sitting and thinking
in silence bro let's be honest maybe a
week or two in you're gonna have that
first glimpse of having no thoughts just
for a few seconds it's very liberating
when you first feel that and you're
gonna be like what the hell was that but
then the second you become conscious
about that you start having more
thoughts now again and you're like oh I
lost that you know and you try to get
back into that state but the more you
try the harder it's going to be you kind
of scrap that you go a few more days and
then you have it again within the first
month you'll be able to have more of
those I guess free liberating spaces
where you have no thoughts and you're
just there in silence in the dark
thinking of nothing
eventually the more you do this you will
be able to have these at will you will
be able to basically get into that state
where you're thinking of nothing very
easily I can do that in the span of a
few seconds I'm not saying this to both
but I'm saying it takes practice Yeah
right and the more you get into this you
can not only induce it at will but you
can prolong it for as long as you want
sometimes I can get into that state for
many minutes
um and have no thoughts and the point of
this is eventually you get to a point
where this is called subconscious
filtering so you will basically get rid
of a lot of your thoughts in your mind
that are bothering you and that will
bring up the things that you are not
processing so now one day you're
meditating bro and you're thinking of
someone that did you dirty when you were
four years old you were like what the
hell why am I where did this come from
is this is this even real did this
actually happen to me did I did I get
done dirty from a family member when I
was a kid I'm serious bro like people
have these deep dramatic abuse and
things come up and it's not until this
point that you actually realize that
there's a lot going on in your
subconscious mind so the subconscious
mind is actually where like 70 to 90 of
our thoughts are processing in which
means that all the things that you know
about you so your name is Sheed you know
you're this tall this age you're working
on your real estate thing you're doing
your own thing all these things that we
have known as our identity these are
just in our conscious mind which is just
10 to 25 of our consciousness of our
entire thoughts of our entire real us
the real you most of you you're not even
aware of bro when you meditate it brings
up these things to the surface so it
could be something where someone lied to
you a month ago right and you're like
bro why am I why am I even thinking of
that but it just goes to show you how
much your subconscious brain holds on to
yeah might be someone that like an old
partner that cheated on you it might be
something where your parents were
basically you know they had the best for
you they wanted the best for you in
terms of intention but maybe they were a
little bit too harsh and even though now
they've changed you're still holding on
to a little bit of that that you know
tension and animosity you know because
at the end of the day we're all slaves
to our nurse to some degree right yeah
yeah and and it's like it brings you
that in a way where it kind of just
presents it to you now you can either
suppress it but don't do that there's a
reason it's coming to you now because
you're meditating you're ready to
process and heal it so you're basically
connecting these dots and the reason is
this is what people do when they pay a
therapist the therapist just connects
these dots for you yeah you don't need
to waste your money you could do this
yourself I know this is the unsexy
answer it's going to take a long time
but it's better you do this now than
later so this is kind of the first way
that I recommend people and the second
way is journaling journaling is amazing
because journaling you're basically
writing these things down and this is
for people that are already very heady
maybe just being in the company of their
own mind is scary to them bro yeah so I
recommend them just be calm turn the
lights on turn on the candle whatever
you want get everything going set the
mood and just Journal now a lot of
people are going to already start you
know especially the heady people they're
going to wonder what do I write is it
gratitude journaling is it this type of
journaling is it like a diarrhea right
what I did every day bro just shut up
and just grab a piece of paper and yeah
right don't ask questions like what am I
going to do with the pen and paper
listen I guarantee you within 30 seconds
of your writing you're already gonna be
just flowing it's a flow State the first
day you're probably writing what you did
that day it is what it is second third
day probably more of that eventually
you're gonna and if you keep this
practice up you're gonna start writing
about some deep stuff the things that
will come up in meditation you're gonna
be writing about these things now and
the thing is the reason journaling I
believe right and this is not medical
advice the reason I believe journaling
is superior because I've I've coached
dozens of men with this too is when you
Journal you're basically keeping a
backup copy of what's up here yeah so
your mind basically lets go of things
because it knows you know what there's a
copy saved up just like if you have
something on your computer and you don't
want to lose it right but you know where
your computer's acting up now it's
getting slow it's you know the ram is is
overclocked bro the hard drive is going
through the roof you know you can't even
move the cursor without lagging so what
do you do you take some type of a drive
or some type of big hard drive external
hard drive and you basically keep a copy
in that and when you keep a copy in that
you can delete what's in your computer
and that's the same with the mind your
subconscious is holding on to all this
stuff why because Allah has hardwired us
that way because
life is easy bro we're living in a time
where it's the hard times have created
weak men right and now the weak men or
sorry the hard times have created strong
men strong men have created good times
but now we're kind of in where Good
Times created weak men and now we're
suffering with the consequences of the
weak men creating Hard Times yeah so now
life is is is hard but it's it's still
easy in some ways bro yeah I can go on
my phone and I can literally press two
buttons and I got food at my doorstep
yeah life is easy bro everyone's on
recruit difficulty so because life is
easy
we don't we don't have actual stressors
bro of like Predators coming after us
you know enemy tribes coming after us
like we did even hundreds or thousands
of years ago because of this our bodies
have not changed so everything is still
a micro fight or flight survival stress
you know what I mean yeah you lose your
job bro you're still gonna be fine right
but your body's gonna be like panicking
like what is going on
and the thing is all these things that
your body holds on to it weighs on your
spirit and on your mind when you Journal
you write it down so you're telling your
subconscious that I don't need to
remember these things for my Survival
anymore because if I write it down it's
already there I can always go back to it
if I need to so then your mind lets go
of these things and that's how you do
subconscious filtering through
journaling instead of meditation but
they're both very valuable and over time
you will basically unlearn and get rid
of this baggage that you have right
yeah that that really does make a lot of
sense I think uh everybody should
Journal I think that and meditation I
think those are great ways I also do
want to say though I feel like like you
were saying uh as far as uh the things
in your mind and everything like that if
you everything you do is based off of
stuff that happened in your past like
everything like everything I'm talking
about the way you talk to people like
you got social anxiety it could be a it
could be uh something that happened in
your past the reason why you don't want
to uh you got issues with talking to
people nowadays so what I feel like
that's a that's like a good part of
self-improvement is just trying to learn
yourself and also like I said uh
y'all got the internet too it started
Living in real life because it's a lot
of Islams out there feminism all these
isms and everything it's making weak men
all that stuff is making weak man but
you're going to if you if you go outside
that's why that's one thing I want to
tell people to to go outside and
actually just experience the real world
for what it is instead of what you see
on the internet because if you look on
the internet the world blowing up right
now everything they're saying everything
is wrong with the world all this but in
real life I'm not going to say all
that's out there like that and also I
said a good thing to do for my Muslims
out here connect connect with some
brothers connect with some brothers
y'all you have to get together you have
to get yourself around people that have
the same
the same uh ideas and everything and the
same Focus that you have and that
definitely helps you care a lot of
things but it's definitely good to
journal and all that too so you can
learn why you do certain things because
that's that's gonna be your biggest
thing in self-improvement learn it why
you do so to improve it because you
don't know why you do it how you gonna
improve it you're just gonna keep saying
oh well I don't know why I do this I
don't know why I do this why do I why I
have social anxiety why I can't talk to
people why do I have issues doing this
and that you learn that by figuring out
where it started and that's where you
can start improving it
Honda bro get off social media you're
right what are these men doing do you
know how many people I find like I'm
talking grown men bro all they do is
just post pictures of themselves bro
yeah yeah and it's like bro why are you
so insecure you need all these likes and
all these comments to know that you're
something yeah but then behind closed
doors all I imagine is a guy taking a
thousand selfies bro wasting hours oh
which one's the best one to post which
one do I look the best in and then oh
I'm gonna delete this oh I'm gonna re
you know re-upload this bro it's so
cringe like what are you doing as a man
just imagine bro the prophet saw him
bled and and lived his life got
persecuted and and literally died for
this religion of Islam to basically
relay this message from Allah just for
you to do this bro as a grown man right
what are you doing and and this isn't a
knock on social media but understand
that social media
it's a necessary evil I have social
media yeah I use it for business if I
didn't I tell everyone in my circle this
I would not be on social media bro I
have YouTube and Instagram bro they're
all intertwined I don't have anything
else I don't have a tick tock yeah maybe
that's gonna change soon because I'm
revamping my channel right yeah
um I use Instagram again just for
business I have a YouTube channel I
don't have Twitter I don't know Snapchat
I don't have faith I have Facebook you
know family group chat you already know
that's it bro there's there's no need
for this and the thing is Tate said this
best social media basically deletes one
side of the argument yeah and reports a
false sense of reality what does he mean
by this if we have and and this I'm
going to be speaking about in Minecraft
all right so I'm not speaking about real
life here in Minecraft you got the left
you got the right and they're basically
two two sides of the same coin
but they're going to show you only one
side yeah all of a sudden they're gonna
show you everyone posting a black Square
on their Instagram feed
and perhaps not everyone feels that way
but because that's all you're going to
see you're going to think oh everyone
cares about this one thing yeah this is
the narrative therefore you know they
know how to work with our hardwired you
know safety mechanisms as men and women
it's like that tribe mind you know we
don't want to be basically disowned by
the tribe and this is not some shitty
evolutionary biology or anything I'm
just speaking you know in
non-evolutionary biology at least not in
darwinian uh biology right at the end of
the day we don't want to get disowned by
the tribe by the family and that's why
women particularly have groupthink
because for them to be left without a
protector is far more consequential than
a man but men have it too so it's kind
of like if I don't agree with everyone
then I'm going to be disowned by the
tribe I'm going to be left to survive
and be stranded on my own so therefore
let me always be appeased and in sync
with the tribe this is this is um
hardwired mechanisms work and social
media uses this to basically allow you
to be programmed because it knows if you
don't agree with the mainstream status
quo okay
you're off to the streets bro you're off
to just be left hanging to dry bro and
this is why they will basically
I'm not going to talk about a lot of the
heinous events that have happened in the
last two to three years you guys should
know this right
um
and at the end of the day why did they
force us all these things why did they
force us to do all these things to wear
all these things to put all these things
in our body to stay at home why did they
do a lot of these things the reason that
they did a lot of these things is
basically control yeah and at the end of
the day
if you are a slave to something else
and they're your God lowercase G then
you cannot fully have that connection
with uppercase G God you can it's not
gonna work out bro it's mutually
exclusive to some extent and this is not
to say that you can't be close to Allah
while still listening to music or being
addicted to substances or anything like
that that's all I'm saying yeah but if
you get to a point where you're not even
questioning what you're putting in your
body not even doing research you're not
even worrying and thinking twice where
am I going why am I staying at home yeah
think why am I scared of this whatever
then you got to start asking yourself
like why are you giving something more
power than it deserves and social media
will do that to you it'll be a very
slippery slope it almost gets to a point
where if there's a trend and everyone's
doing that Trend you're gonna take time
out of your day to do that Trend too
right and it's it's cringe seeing men do
all these little cringy Ted Talk dances
and all this type of stuff bro and it is
what it is bro I don't I don't get mad
at them because there's a level of
understanding that we are societally
programmed I get it yeah so at some
level we are victims and I'm not trying
to make this completely on us so yes we
do live in a society that conditions us
to be weak
but what are you going to do after you
find out are you going to be a victim of
your circumstances or are you going to
be a Victor where you realize that you
know what I gotta conquer I gotta change
my life even though Society breeds
degenerate weak men
because I know this I can be different
and because I want to be different I got
to do different I gotta move different
it's no longer going to be just oh my
dad was an alcoholic so
no bro they literally did scientific you
know primary peer-reviewed literature
there's studies to prove that in a lot
of uh the monozygotic twin studies
meaning that they're identical twins
right so they're not like fraternal
twins or anything like that and they
were basically born with the same
genetics 100 genetic compatibility right
and one twin grows up to be one certain
type of way and the other twin grows up
completely different based on
environment so environment does play a
big factor so using this excuse that you
know what my mama did this my daddy did
this because of that I'm I'm like this
no bro that's that's to some extent it's
not gonna it's gonna work it's valid but
then after that it's not gonna work
right so Allah is not gonna basically uh
hold anyone else accountable for you at
the end of the day when the things that
you've done were by your own two hands
right yes Allah is going to hold them
accountable for why you they might have
pushed you that way right for example
um a lot of people uh ask this question
if I bully someone and they end up
deleting themselves who's responsible
and first thing I tell them bro I'm not
a chef like don't don't ask me yeah
anything like that but just rationally
you know approaching this
if you bullied them even though they
deleted themselves you're still going to
be responsible I don't know if it's for
them deleting themselves but you're
gonna be responsible for why you push
them to that right why did you have to
believe them why did you have to put
them down why didn't you love for your
Muslim brother and sister why don't you
bring them up why don't you help them
right so you're gonna be responsible for
that they're still going to be
responsible for what they did right to
that extent right unless they were
obviously like mentally UNS you know not
yeah yeah or intoxicated or something
like that right but if they in a
conscious sober state of mind and a good
state of heart in a sound State they
deleted themselves bro they did that to
themselves right
and at the end of the day long story
short it's it's a very deep black hole
when it comes to social media women
particularly and this is this is this is
something that I don't want to use this
up I don't want to miss this opportunity
to clarify yeah sisters we love you we
protect you we cherish you we value you
you're so much more important than to
just put yourself out there with just
basically when a woman displays her
beauty to non-musl non-mahram meaning
not her husband then not her you know
father and those that are allowed to see
her without hijab right women that are
beautifying themselves for social media
they're showing themselves off what are
you doing right at the end of the day I
get it hijab is a journey but those that
are publicizing this journey come on and
we know there's a Hadith where the
Prophet saw mentions that a woman that
engages in she won't she won't go to
Jannah bro this is an authentic Hadith I
can I can put it up in the description
if you guys want because a lot of women
are like oh where's the proof of this
where's the proof of that listen yeah
it's authentic and at the end of the day
this is not a game this is not a joke
topology is serious so it doesn't mean
now you got to delete your social media
overnight right it's a process right you
post pictures of yourself and with
makeup and all this lower the frequency
first right then eventually ask yourself
why are you posting these yes the likes
and the and the comments and the
validation and the DMS it makes you feel
good right but it doesn't make you feel
good spiritually it just makes your ego
go through the roof and you're enough to
go through the roof ask yourself why are
you doing this right limit how much you
post limit how much you're giving random
people access to your brain for and your
body for and then eventually you can
chill out and slowly delete some posts
slowly clean up your social media to the
point where now you're talking just
messaging friends and that's it and then
eventually you can get to a point where
you delete social media because with men
We're not gonna fall into this over
obsessive need for validation as easily
as women it does happen to men
unfortunately yeah it's not as easy as
women because women are emotional
creatures you hear what I mean women are
because you're emotional you're more
vulnerable to emotional I guess
turbidities in the day sometimes it's
high sometimes it's low sometimes you're
happy sometimes you're sad and as a
woman you're gonna feel insecure
sometimes it just comes with the game
right why well one Society literally
programs women to fuel inferior yeah
unless they look like this ideal I guess
Hollywood figure you get what I mean it
purports this ideal woman and any woman
that's a real normal woman is not going
to look like that bro right they're not
gonna be photoshopped with an anime
physique it's not gonna work bro come on
you know so what they'll do is women
they'll basically prey on women's
insecurities yep Brands plastic surgery
the whole shebang skin care skin care
bro what the hell you don't need all
this these chemicals for and now you got
an insecure woman yeah so this insecure
woman now is basically going to use this
to mask the insecurity they got filters
bro don't think all these things are by
coincidence now nothing happened by
coincidence yeah you got filters to make
a 50 year old woman look like she's 25
you know wrinkle free they can put
makeup on bro if I take a wet wipe and
just wipe a woman's face 90 of her face
is gone bro but why why why are they at
this point it's not even you anymore
yeah yeah what are you trying to look
like yeah and my point is
at that point all she has to do is post
a picture to feel like she's it bro yeah
yeah and and it's very easy but it's
fake at the end of the day all these men
are getting is free access to you right
anything for nothing and I've seen a lot
of sisters unfortunately it's a very
slippery slope from Instagram
to only fans and it's more prominent
among the non-muslim sisters yeah I
admit it but Muslim sisters are still
getting on only fans right why because
no one knows their identity so they can
kind of be just a faceless hijabilist
body just selling whatever from that and
then after only fans what do you think
is gonna happen so
at the end of the day I think Muslim
women should protect themselves and
women in general yeah generally
understand what social media is for
and social media was not designed to
liberate you it was designed to oppress
you and control you fast but when you
hear a man like me telling you to get
off social media you're gonna think
you're being controlled yeah you're not
being liberated but in actuality Society
wants you to feel liberated while being
Shackled and controlled yeah and it's
just delusion bro hey but if you
actually free yourself it might seem
controlling at first because controlling
has been defined the wrong way by
Society so as soon as you liberate
yourself you're gonna feel free and
you're gonna feel like I don't have to
actually worry about what these men
think these random men bro I just have
to worry about my husband if I'm married
yeah or you know that's it and I could
just be myself I don't have to worry
about every time I want to go out I
gotta cake up and do all this nonsense
and if you have a husband you can please
your husband that's it and life is easy
bro life is simple
yeah but I do believe that like social
media definitely tries to play on uh
women's Securities insecurities and
everything like that and that has a lot
to play along with uh how they're trying
to pressure and everything like that
another thing too is the weak men it's
the weak men that be giving them that
attention and everything like that and
that will mess it up the Sims bro
in a sense man like they they be giving
them all the attention and everything
and that just messes the whole thing up
because it boosts their ego it boosts
their ego so they feel like every time
they gotta go out they gotta put makeup
on they gotta do all this they gotta do
all that they gotta feel less about
themselves Allah already gave you a lot
gave you your blueprint that's your
blueprint that's your card that you have
to work with but Society will beat that
out of you beat that out of you that
you're not perfect you don't you're not
this you're not that and that just makes
you do stuff that
you shouldn't be doing basically you
shouldn't be doing like it it doesn't
make sense to me man it's it's social
media though but like I said why I
recommend people using social media for
us business purposes only to connect
with friends and family that what you
should use it for you shouldn't be using
it but if you pay attention to the
algorithm the algorithm will put stuff
in front of you that you don't need to
be seeing it definitely does it could be
on the men's side of the women's side
with men they like to show them women
half naked and all that so they can feel
and it plays into it because a lot of
men spend money on uh women's only fans
and everything like that because
they be they be seeing they'll be seeing
them have have that look at how they're
looking on in an angle get into all that
you know how it is man maybe maybe uh
anime figure all kind of stuff like that
so that's that's one thing that they try
to do plan to men's insecurities and
everything like that
yeah it's very it's very crazy man like
the way the world going I advise men to
just like I said you gonna have to
find you gotta find a lot that's all the
best they say find a locker that's
definitely going to help you out a lot
and critical thinking too man you got to
learn how the critical thing and not
have that victim mindset for that
victimizer
what's up that's it bro the next thing
is Fitness all right why Fitness what's
what's this whole thing about Fitness I
thought body positivity I thought it's
it's who I am on the inside that matters
yeah bro shut up listen you got no
excuse to be looking the way you looking
and to be out of shape and not be doing
something about it now here's the thing
I'm not coming for brothers that are out
of shape I just said if you're out of
shape and not doing anything about it
right because if you're out of shape and
you're doing something about it who you
are up here is shredded six-pack this is
who you want to be but who you are
outside might be from years of
overeating and all this but at least
you're making steps towards it so I'm
not gonna come for you bro but the
brothers are out of shape and not doing
anything about it bro you pulling up to
the massages you might be a Sheikh you
might be an Imam and this is not a job
at your scholarship not not even the
slightest but do you not understand the
cedar do you not understand the Deen
that you're preaching or the prophet
saws never had his belly over his chest
there were narrations mentioning his
chest was over his belly bro yeah and do
you not do not want to model the best of
creation right did Allah give you this
body as a test
like what Quran are you reading bro is
there like another you know Edition
where it says just focus on the inner me
body positivity don't worry about your
physique no rather the process on
mentioned we should have San excellence
in everything that we do right not just
in matters of Dunya but in Dean too yeah
so if you really internalize that and
you walk the walk you're not just gonna
talk to talk right then you understand
that Jim is important nutrition is
important and this is why we're going to
very easily just quickly you know go
over this in a very skimmable way it's
not gonna be anything deep nothing
complex I'm not going to tell you to
macros none of this simply put number
one cut out processed food stop having
all this junk bro I cannot tell you what
I eat in a day without 99 of people not
believing what I eat I'm I'm eating
probably one meal a day this is just
this is just what I do I have about a
thousand to 1200 calories a day maybe a
thousand to 1300 that's really low right
but I don't feel hungry because what I
eat and this is all I eat right yeah I
eat lamb chicken
all the eggs I'm talking the organic
free-range eggs we can talk about that
in a little bit
um I'm having
vegetables
I'm having
that's it bro yes that's really it just
me
and vegetables and eggs I don't you
don't need anything else
you get the fiber from the vegetables
you get the micronutrients the vitamins
and the minerals you get the protein
from the meat that's it I'm getting
about 170 grams of protein a day which
is pretty high just from this real food
you don't need all this processed
garbage I don't eat I barely eat out
even when I eat out I look at what I eat
I rarely have things that come out of a
box you know if something has a has a
label on it it's packaged or processed
I'm probably not gonna eat that bro
right I eat things that are natural That
Grew on God's green earth such as
animals and crops that's it bro mentally
and physically you're going to feel
insane so this is number one try to cut
out junk food and if you can't because
you're an NPC I get it limit how much
junk food that you consume yeah limited
definitely three times a week that's it
exactly bro yeah and another thing is
drink a lot of water that's so I try to
get a minimum of a gallon of water a day
yeah sometimes a little bit more than
that so that's about four liters that I
try to aim for a day and yes you're
gonna be going to the washroom a lot
what do you expect you're just gonna
hold all this oh no yeah it's okay it's
not the end of the world right yeah but
drink a lot of water and space it
through the day don't chug on this water
you don't be hydrated be good yeah have
a lot of lemons too I have about like a
lemon a day
um I try to have because because lemons
will give you that high vitamin C which
is really good for your immune system
without too much carbs you know what I
mean so yeah we're having mangoes and
oranges and all this uh another thing is
I have organic free-range eggs this is
different it's a little bit pricier than
normal eggs it's not but you got to
invest in yourself you're out here
spending on only fans models bro and
you're not gonna buy organic free range
eggs come on explain to me the
dissonance bro yeah you know you're
spending money on things you shouldn't
be so at the end of the day a carton of
12 attack eggs cost probably them as
much as a shawarma bro yeah and you're
gonna be like oh I don't have money to
afford that bro just don't have that
Shawarma you know what I mean free range
organic eggs are allowed to go outside
yeah they basically get real sunlight so
the vitamin D that they have is what's
coming to you right the eggs that you
find that are cheap right Cheaper by the
Dozen like a dollar or two these are the
eggs that they're in a tiny little
Cooper
exactly they never see the light of day
they never see the sun there's probably
10 hens in a square foot I kid you no
I'm not making this up by the way ten
hens in a square foot and what type of
life is that they're just injecting them
with pro hormones antibiotics I kid you
not and that's that's what you're eating
that's the chicken that you eat right
these animals grow up on soy yeah which
will feminize you they grow up on it's
not real food that they're they're
they're having yeah they're they're
caged you know what I mean and when you
eat that it'll basically shoot up your
inflammation right I want to get too
sciency but we have omega-3 and omega-6
right
Omega-3s are good for us omega-6 are not
really what's good for us
omega-6 is from what I know it's one of
the two
um because I am kind of sleep deprived
bro so you got to forgive me but one of
the two I believe it's omega-6 is
pro-inflammatory so chickens will have a
crazy high ratio of omega-6 to three
yeah if they're indoors because of all
the chemicals and stuff but when you eat
real eggs and real chickens that are
roaming you don't have that problem
right these these chickens are out here
having dirt they're not dirt like worms
and yeah other animals and bugs that's
that's what chickens are supposed to do
yeah and you'll feel the difference in
your testosterone so this is number two
another thing is going to be to sleep
right there's a reason Allah has made
sleep about a third of our entire life
in this Dunya so you know how when we
were in the barzak bro we were in the in
the realm of the souls and Allah asks us
that question you know my slave do you
wanna do you want to go into the Dunya
you want to live this life in the in the
chances that you could go to Jannah you
could be better than the Angels if you
actually live a rightful life or do you
not and
yeah and we all took on that challenge
bro yeah a lot of atheists were like I
didn't ask to be born you quite did yeah
you just forgot anyway at that time when
Allah you know sent us into this this
Dunya we understand how much of a test
this is when you really understand that
we took Allah's challenge we really
accepted this here's the thing because
we accepted this we know how important
every living second is of the day right
one third of the day approximately is
sleep
this is very important so it might sound
like oh why am I wasting time sleeping
I'd rather overwork listen nothing is
more important than sleep yeah so if you
want to get on top of your sleep start
waking up early start sleeping early
right I don't practice this myself I'm
just saying it as it is because I don't
want to be a hypocrite so I'm telling
you like I'm in a point in my life right
now where I am getting more work done at
night yeah and it is what it is post
Ramadan bro I'm trying to adjust but the
idea obviously we can still do the ideal
is sleep earlier wake up earlier don't
eat and drink too much before bed yeah
so in the last like two hours before bed
don't eat and drink too much otherwise
you're not gonna sleep fully rested and
relaxed right a lot is going to be full
you're gonna wake up wanting rush into
the washroom you know what I mean
sleep in the dark pitch black I'm
talking
in blackout curtains if you can if you
can't get and get an eye mask right
sleeping mask shout out to my boy Angelo
from the three Muslims he put me on game
on the eye mask with him in New York for
a week and the whole time bro I was
using his eye mask he wasn't even using
his own eye mask it was that good I was
like bro I'm gonna steal your eye mask
he was gonna give it to me too but I was
like nah bro I'm not gonna do that much
come on yeah but it was good and I asked
him to send me a link and he did yeah so
time mask is key
um sleeping in relaxed comfortable loose
clothing nothing too tight not being too
warm not being too hot
and if you are married which inshallah
Allah can you know get you to that point
if you level up and ask Allah enough for
a Pious wife all right
sleeping with the spouse is uncomparable
compared to sleeping by yourself I'm not
talking about intimacy I'm talking just
sleeping with someone it's so much so
much better it's more oxytocin you feel
more relaxed it boosts your testosterone
it's much better all right all these
things all these factors in
you will have much better sleep quality
than if you don't now I still want you
guys to go to a medical practitioner or
a sleep therapist
and go into a lot of disorders if you
still have bad sleep sometimes you might
have sleep apnea sometimes you might
have some actual problem or a medical
condition that needs to be sorted out
but in most cases I generally think it's
as simple as the things that I'm saying
right to have bulletproof sleep yeah
yeah that makes a lot of sense that does
make a lot of sense you teach me some
things too but I ain't know about the
lemon and everything like that like
eating a lemon is good too I ain't know
that yeah lemon's good bro I'm not gonna
do anything crazy you know and say eat
the skin too bro none of that bro yeah
um but what I will say is juice the
lemon right and just put in some water
and it's fine and it's really gonna help
your skin it's gonna help your pH you're
not gonna need fake chemicals when you
got the real deal yeah this is going to
be number one
um or number three or four the next
thing and we're gonna quickly wrap up
Fitness
is if you're doing this with Whole Foods
you're eating the types of foods that
I'm telling you yeah meat protein
vegetables
barely any carbs if you have to listen I
I personally don't eat carbs like yeah
really but if you have the carbs like
potatoes bro potatoes and sweet potatoes
you know I do eat carbs like by
extension of the vegetables and fruits I
don't eat starchy carbs high glycemic
um you know white rice
oatmeal cereal I don't do this stuff by
the way yogurt none of this but if you
have to do potatoes potatoes are better
for you now
the main takeaway is if you are eating
these types of foods you can't overeat
two three four thousand calories you can
it's fast it's only if you're eating
calorie dense junk food you go to
McDonald's bro if you buy a Double
Quarter Pounder with cheese right and I
guarantee you bro
the stuff they put in this it doesn't
fill you up no so you're probably gonna
get you're probably gonna get two
Burgers bro minimal right yeah I don't
know a single person that's gone to
McDonald's and got one Burger in front
of me I've never seen that so you're
getting me two burgers yeah you're
getting probably one fry probably a
medium or large fry and you know they
got the cookies at the front bro and you
know and you know the way they only put
one or two cookies there and you're
gonna be telling yourself oh that's a
sign it was there for me yeah like my
cookies they're holding bro there's only
two left I gotta get it I can't just not
get it yeah you get that it's time for a
drink they're gonna ask you what you
want to drink you got all these variety
all these you got 10 types of coke now
and you're gonna be like oh which one do
I want you're gonna probably get a
McFlurry bro wrestler yeah yeah you know
you're having 3 500 calories in
everything you just ate
and you're gonna be hungry in two hours
again thanks
but the foods that I'm telling you bro
like I'm not telling people to do this
by the way I'm just sharing what I do
yeah my first meal is around nine to ten
P.M
literally like two hours three hours
before I go to sleep that's my first
meal wow and that's that's all me and
and then I don't eat for the next entire
day until this time and I'm not hungry
bro I literally am not hungry I'm
chilling I'm going to the gym I'm
working out I'm doing cardio I'm doing
me and it is what it is like it's
amazing whereas if I actually eat more
frequently through the day I'll get
hungrier so the secret to weight loss or
fat losses is going to be to get into a
style of intermittent fasting yeah right
and the reason is
whenever you wake up in the day the
second you eat something you basically
get what's known as an insulin Spike so
an insulin spike is basically going to
be insulin is a hormone that basically
soaks up carbs that you eat from your
blood into your cells and it just
delivers it where it's supposed to be
kind of like a mailman takes your
packages and puts it you know brings it
to you from the shipping facility to
your house to your doorstep so similarly
insulin basically takes carbs from the
food you eat into the blood and then it
takes it from the blood into your cells
it delivers it where it needs to be very
simple yeah so insulin Spike means when
you eat a lot of carbs it spikes up how
much insulin your body releases so it
can do their job and process these carbs
the second you get your first insulin
Spike
the next one is going to come very soon
after right so what I'm trying to say is
if you wake up and you eat a breakfast
at 9am 8am 7 A.M by noon you're going to
get another instance but you're gonna
get hungry again right and by 3 P.M
you're gonna get hungry again yeah 7 P.M
you're getting hungry again for me
because I've trained my body to not eat
until let's say one meal a day or like
you know after Maghrib after Isha or
around Maghrib I'm basically not gonna
have any insulin Spike when I wake up so
I don't wake up starving bro I don't
wake up hungry like if you have a crap
ton of carbs before bed you're gonna
wake up starving bro oh yeah art burn
you're gonna all these things you know
you're gonna be like oh I can't I can
only think of food I don't get this bro
I get all my work done during the day
I'm chilling yeah so
I'm not a slave to food and you know the
stone of the process of Solomon is to
eat as less as possible yeah he would
just take a few bites here and they're
barely eating and the process I'll
mentioned if you can't do that then have
one third food one-third water and one
third air in your stomach a lot of
people just jump straight to this no the
process I'll mentioned if you can't do
the former yeah then do this and even
then
he would make sure everyone else is fed
before he fed himself right there were
narrations where he would basically tie
like you know like a rock or something
on his abdomen to basically look like
he's Fed so other people wouldn't
wouldn't feel like you know they're
overstepping and eating more than the
messenger of Allah this is what he would
do and and why because he understood
that this life is bigger than just
temporary worldly delusions you know
what I mean he would not sleep in the
most comfortable beds bro being the
messenger of Allah the best of creation
so I saw him he wouldn't and he would
have other people around him more
comfortable than him in Dunya because he
understood his priorities so I'm not
saying not to enjo what I'm saying is
detached to these worldly drugs they are
drugs bro if you knew the chemicals they
put in our food yeah just the
psychoactive chemicals to be addicting
when he really study the pharmacology
and science of food is dangerous bro
so all these things they're just
distractions see I'm from Bangladesh
right yeah so my grandfather Allah he
passed away in January and me and my dad
had to take a quick last minute trip to
Bangladesh to you know bury him and to
do the janaza the funeral and then we
came back it was literally like five six
days max yeah and
I remember when we went there
um I want to give a huge shout out by
the way to my dad Obama he's a he's a
forest bro because him losing his father
yeah in in January continuing to work as
a man continuing to provide continuing
to just do all of his responsibilities
and I'm sure at Parts bro he was it was
killing him inside he was probably
aching but at the end of the day
regardless of how he felt he still
showed up every single day as a man and
did what he needed to do right and at
the end of the day this is the
definition of kawam when it's like when
Allah says in the in the Quran that men
should be kawam you know that you got to
be a real man about it you can't just be
a little ass boy so regardless of how he
felt he could have made these excuses oh
I lost my father I'm gonna take time off
this I'm gonna do this no nothing
he processed it and handled it like a
man however he could bless him and he
continued to just do what he had to do
as a man every single day right anyway
we're in Bangladesh right yeah and bro
you know the food back home these people
eat five six times a day they got all
these curries and rotis and all this
good stuff right I love it I love it
they thought I was weird for eating at
that point I wasn't eating one meal a
day I was eating two meals a day they
thought I was weird for doing that
they'll take it as disrespect if you
don't eat their food you know how it is
yeah so I'm like I don't really want it
yeah bro I'm seeing people going on
first yeah and they're going on second
yep you're going on thirds listen the
food was so good
I wanted to get seconds every single
time but I didn't I just didn't because
I knew it's a trap bro yeah and I
literally came back from Bangladesh by
the way what I'm about to say right now
not trying to you know boast yeah but
this is pretty commendable yeah I came
back from a vacation back home and I did
not gain a single pound this is unheard
of bro yeah you can't go back to
Bangladesh Pakistan India Middle East
wherever all these good foods and come
back with no weight gain because I
stayed on top of it yeah I knew bro if I
get lost in the sauce I'm coming back
with 10 15 pounds yeah yeah so
and I saw people around me taking
seconds it looked so good to me bro but
I knew if I do this in another two three
hours they're gonna bring desserts
they're gonna bring snacks there's no
point and I was also kind of it was a
very emotional time too because my
grandfather just passed away so go in
there and and burying him it was it was
a very different experience than a lot
of other debts where it's kind of like
you just hear someone pass away yeah but
you're not active actively going and
seeing the body and seeing you know once
it's prepared and cleaned and then
burying him with your own two hands
right which I did with my dad and and
his brother which is the three of us
luring him to the Grave that's a
different experience bro it's gonna hit
you more different differently and more
intensely about the the finality of life
right how temporary everything is right
so alhamdulillah that's another thing
that happened and it brought me closer
and I didn't I didn't really change my
diet in that a lot of people they change
their diet to the tune of the drums of
their day yeah I'm traveling now so I'm
not gonna have I'm not gonna be able to
eat my normal food so I'm just gonna eat
out bro why get an Airbnb don't get a
hotel hotels are traps get an Airbnb you
got a kitchen go grocery shopping bro I
went with Angelo to Iceland right on a
little trip to Iceland and if I can
recall all we ate was lamb fish sweet
potatoes that we literally went to
airbnbs that had kitchens yeah we went
to grocery stores yeah bro you're in
Iceland you want to see the volcanoes
you want to see the glaciers you're
gonna get what's from shaytan telling
you don't waste time cooking it didn't
take that much time right it took us
probably 30 minutes to make these meals
together every single night yeah it was
healthy and we were good and we saved
money too at the end of the day
um so this is just like a side thing
like there's no excuse you can have for
now
unless you have literally you're going
through something crazy bro like a
divorce yeah break up something like
that even then bro I've been through
these difficult times in my life like
losing a loved one or you know having a
very shift or severe shift in my life
circumstances right
and I get it I've been through that but
I didn't fold Under Pressure I didn't
resort to eating trash I did it so but I
get it everyone's gonna be different
some people have stress eating which and
binge eating which is itself you should
get that checked out yeah but at the end
of the day there's no excuse to maintain
a certain standard for the sake of Allah
under any circumstance possible this one
for example discipline exactly this
standard is something that you need to
set for yourself I can set this for you
she'd ski cancer yeah three Muslims
podcast can't set this for you Muhammad
hijab Kan said this for you mail a
blessing you got to set this for your
own self yeah so it doesn't matter you
know what my standards five times a day
are going to pray yeah I'm in the
airport
oh what are people gonna think should I
just miss a prayer should I pray later
no pray
this standard might be I'm gonna do one
hour of physical activity per day yeah
non-negotiable oh I'm traveling I don't
have a gym okay go on a walk the hotel
Airbnb a little bit of a gym in the in
the in the lobby or something
um no matter what I'm gonna try to eat
as clean as possible right cool you're
traveling you you know all you see are
different junk food bro go on Google
Maps find out a nice Afghan place with
rice and Kebab something a little bit
more cleaner than this processed
artificial burgers and stuff I'll eat
that so the standard that you set as a
man should be followed through no matter
what every single day it shouldn't
matter how you feel it shouldn't matter
what's going on how much money you got
in your bank account if you your wife
still loves you if your parents are
still on good terms with you
nothing none of this no matter what the
standard that you have in front of Allah
non-negotiable never changes
right yeah that that definitely that's
definitely a deep dive in Fitness and
everything like that in nutrition like
yeah you you gave you gave everybody a
lot I want you I want everybody watching
this to take that in and like I said and
develop a strategy that works for you
because like like he said I can't help I
can't give you that strategy to the T
fight I can't give you the strategy to a
t a three months the whole podcast and
give you the strategy to it you got to
learn it yourself but don't go back on
your word discipline is what's really
going to help you self-improve you got
to have discipline whatever you do like
I said that's you go ahead let me let me
let me give you a story bro yeah and I
want to take too long because we both
gotta go to Juma no unless you've
already been but yeah yeah we gotta go
so
I have a task right that I have to get
done yeah and basically for the three
Muslims me Ramen hope we all have
different roles and responsibilities so
in our streams anyone that watches our
streams they know that we have a little
bit of a countdown in the beginning it's
like a five minute countdown yeah no we
are actually in the process of
rebranding our entire Channel clean
logos different thumbnails you're
welcome guys we're handling it but we're
doing a different countdown yeah in the
countdown one of my friends
he's uh he's an influencer he's also uh
you know he's a reciter of the Quran
Aloha preserve him an increase in I mean
we took a a Quran recitation of Surah
Yasin from him
and we basically put it into the
countdown and it's a different countdown
now
so now I have a task of basically taking
the countdown that we have and because I
added a lot of stuff for the channel I
have to now put the audio of uh brother
Yahya of Surah Yasin into the the
countdown and I gotta add in English
translations of the Quran my God bro
listen you know adding captions unless
it's Auto generated bro what what type
of AI can Auto generate out of me bro
they don't know this right now right and
translator it's not happening yeah so I
have to manually do it right all right
yesterday I had something that I just
ran into some problem and I had to
handle this at night right this is the
Dunya shatan's gonna test us either with
our wealth with our family with their
relationships it's normal bro right so I
had something like this come up and I
was supposed to get this done and I
messaged it on me and I was like bro
like you know I'm just handling
something right now I haven't gotten
this done yet yeah because Rami was just
he wanted to go over it and and kind of
you know
he was gonna proofread it kind of make
sure all the words are proper all the
translations are good I didn't
accidentally put one verse translation
to another verse while yahir was
reciting so it's like on point just like
any Quran recitation you find right yeah
so he was he's probably waiting on me
for that so he just messaged me is it
done I was like nah this is what
happened like I didn't give him details
but I was like you know I'm just going
through something right now he's like
um it's okay bro like you know may Allah
make it easy on you like just don't
worry about doing it tonight yeah I'll
just I'll get it from you whenever you
send it yeah yeah bro in that moment I
knew I knew bro once you set a standard
for yourself it doesn't matter how you
feel I'm mentally drained now I'm
physically drained it's late night I'm
like bro I want to go to sleep and I
just did it anyway I didn't go to sleep
until I finished it right so I made sure
everything was done I sent it to the
group chat and Romney's checking over
that he already sent me some feedback by
the way Miller bless him saying Yasin
should be spelled like this and not this
Allah my buttock and I'll finish these
you know final touches today but the
point is I didn't let go of the standard
that I set myself to operate in just for
how I feel right you know the bed is
warm it's cozy under the blanket I'm
tired perfect mood you just want to go
to sleep no bro no like don't don't do
it don't go into rest and comfort until
everything is done as a man yeah and I'm
not telling you to overwork yourself
but if you tell yourself you're gonna do
something
do you really think there's no
consequences when you don't do it and
you don't follow through your
subconscious brain the thing that I'm
telling you is picking up from stuff
that happened to you when you were a kid
all this trauma all this abuse all this
hurt
if the same brain the subconscious is
going to pick up on the things that you
didn't follow through on
so you're quite literally going to have
a negative self-image do you go what I
mean yeah if you say you're gonna do
something and you don't do it you might
tell yourself consciously I'm gonna do
it tomorrow bro your subconscious knows
you're not a capable guy anymore right
it knows it literally knows this guy
said he's gonna do it he didn't do it so
probably next time he's not gonna do it
just be lazy next time let's not even
urge him to go so why are you telling
yourself that your your self-image how
your body and mind perceives you
yourself alone depends on your integrity
as a man Integrity meaning do you follow
through and stay at that standard and
principle that you set under every
circumstance or do you just fold to
whatever Direction the wind blows from
every single day right
yeah like I said I agree it is exact
same way basically discipline that's
going to help your self-improvement
journey a lot like if you have that
discipline to achieve uh things in your
life self-improvement is going to be
easy Journey more or less more or less
everything is discipline like for
example like if you if you're going to
start getting better with uh the Quran
and uh following what Allah tells you to
do discipline you want to get better
with eating discipline you want to get
better going to the gym discipline you
want to get better on social media it's
all discipline what I want you guys to
take away it's a you got you got to
develop something that works for you you
got to develop something where for you
the things you want in our life I advise
people to write down your goals and
everything what you want to achieve out
of life and make a make a method to get
to it because everything's achievable I
don't believe that no one on this planet
can't achieve what they want to do in
their life I believe everyone's here for
a reason everybody has different reason
the reason that you have is not the
reason I have to be here so everybody
everybody has their own reason of doing
things but what you have to do is find a
way to achieve those things find a way
and don't give up don't ever give up
that's one thing I want to tell men to
never give up never give up because you
give up you're further away than what
you would have been if you would have
kept going
you got the pain of discipline or the
pain of regret it's not that much
complicated right you're either gonna
have the hurt on uh you know what I had
to grind now I'm tired uh I have to keep
going I have to endure or you can have
the pain of not getting there in the
first place okay let's think what if I
actually could have achieved it right
let's think about it do it I don't think
nobody's watching this once they get
older and be like man I wish I would
have did this when I was younger I wish
I would have went hard on that business
I want to I wish I would have went hard
in the gym maybe my body would look
better than what it does now like things
like that things like that should make
you just want to stay disciplined on
your goals and everything like that or
like even at like think about Judgment
Day you want to just throw away your
dean and then come to Judgment day and
be like man I wish I would have done
this it's no turn it back it's no no
turn it back anything we're like I want
everybody to keep going with what
they're doing and stay focused like I
said stay focused keep focused on what
you want to do because everybody has
different goals like my goal did for
everybody else goes on on this uh stream
here but I want everybody to just find
what they like to do find what they're
passionate about and go for it go for
everything be do it in a lost you know
good grace should do it like that don't
do it don't do it done your way do it uh
the the right way and everything like
that but find you something find you
everything you want to do in life and
just go achieve it just go work hard
work hard work hard like I said it's a
lot of things that us men have problems
with it's a lot of things that uh like I
said we have it's a lot of mental
problems and everything like that but
don't regret don't worry like I said
don't don't live a life or just I want
you guys live a life of regret I want
you guys to achieve everything you want
to do so like I said go stay focused
that's the best I can tell everybody
stay focused you're going to achieve
your goals to stay focused and develop a
plan meditate Journal do all them things
and things will help you conquer
everything that you have in your mind to
achieve your goals
I like where this is going but make sure
you guys simply put don't be spending
more than you're earning yeah you know
anyone can do this I don't care if
you're self-employed if you're employed
if you're a freelance whatever do not
spend more than you're earning debt is
real yeah you know the day of judgment
do you really when we're when we're only
dead indebted to Allah we only belong to
Allah imagine that they are judging me
like oh there was this this ten thousand
dollars that I owed this person twenty
thousand dollars at this this loan this
mortgage is this and I died with this I
don't know if you want to be in that
particular I want to be a judgment bro
just yeah not even islamically just
think about it bro like you really how
what are you gonna say to Allah and and
at the end of the day we shouldn't be
indebted as human beings as Muslims as
Menin to anyone else yeah no this
doesn't mean you can't take a loan if
it's like Sharia compliant and you do
your best to pay back and you know you
you it's like on an as needed basis like
you desperately need emergency that's a
different thing bro I'm talking people
that are just oh I'm gonna use my nuffs
to have a two thousand dollar credit
card bill this month and I only got paid
a thousand and now the credit card is
due it says ten dollars minimum payment
and I'll just put the rest on on loan or
on interest oh I'll just pay the ten
dollars bro the Dunya is designed to
control you control yourself so that
Dunya can't have any say on controlling
you in the matter whatsoever do not go
into debt do and if you are in it try to
get out of it as soon as possible
stay away from it stay away from that
and financial literacy is Paramount in
your life to level up as a high value
man in Islam and in the Dunya so how do
you do that we'll make a video on it
inshallah yeah there's resources online
try to leave this this Matrix if you're
working in nine to five I'm not going to
knock a nine to five bro do your hustle
but nine to five as long as you're
getting paid and they know that you are
a scarce commodity they're paying you
well because you're not just an employee
they need you yeah they can't have
another firm or company have you right
that's fine but if you're if you're
working on nine to five and you know
that you're replaceable yeah do
something to prepare for something else
I'm not telling you your job right away
have a side hustle have some way out
where you have value that you bring to
the table what I tell people is you was
a 95 as a stepping so you that step is
to to achieve your uh goals and
everything like that like you know what
I'm saying like don't get away from like
I'm not going to tell people not to go
get a nine to five because you start
from zero dollars I advise you because
you're gonna have to work your way up
you got to pay the bills bro yeah you're
gonna have to pay the bills like if
we're if you're our adult you have to
pay the bills you're gonna have to start
somewhere but on your free time I don't
want to hear nobody talking about I'm
tired oh I'm just so sleepy and
everything like that that's slave that's
a slave mind that what they want you to
do they want you to be so tired when you
get off of work that you won't work on
yourself to escape the matrix so
basically what I tell everybody to do is
yeah use that nine to five and step into
it and find what you're passionate about
work on that on the side and then at
some point that side hustle will become
the main hustle then you escape
100 bro I think that was beautifully put
is there anything else that you would
like to talk about bro before we wrap up
the stream any more questions or
anything nah that's it man like I said I
enjoy I enjoyed having you on we need to
do another one on on finances again and
you know talk more deeply into that but
I do uh appreciate you coming through
and everything like that and I just want
to tell everybody if you are not
subscribed to the three Muslim Channel
definitely go check them out the
umbrellas are doing a great thing you
guys check them out they got a lot of a
lot of great podcasts a lot of great
information you've seen today we heard a
lot so yeah go definitely check their
Channel out check out Fire's Channel you
do a fitness coaching too yeah I do
finish coaching websites right there but
in terms of my uh my own YouTube channel
the one that's totaled in this video on
YouTube I'm gonna basically really focus
on my channel in the next few days even
so stay tuned for a lot of real
conversations like this on awesome
self-improvement inshallah
a lot but I want to say uh thank you
everybody for coming to the stream hope
you all enjoyed it how many viewers we
got bro I can't see it uh we had we had
ten we had ten I I gotta reveal we were
rebuilding no that's money bro that's
money listen even if we can help one
person in Spanish well the numbers don't
matter yeah that's why I said nothing
don't matter that's one thing too I want
y'all learn that two chat numbers don't
matter likes don't matter you gotta do
what you want to do in life so yeah but
I hope everybody enjoyed the stream make
sure you guys check out the three Muslim
Channel make sure you guys subscribe to
this channel it's uh we're out of here
you guys be safe you guys enjoy the rest
of your day
Alexa
all right